Now I'm sure you were a pro at what you just did,
so let's try to make things a little more complicated. Now the nice
thing in genetics is if we want to make things complicated, all we
have to do is add one more gene. And boom, we've increased our
complication factor exponentially here. So we are starting kind of slow, we're
just going to try to do two genes at once now instead of one.
Let's try to look at the trait of lactose intolerance and dwarfism at
the same time. Now, the lactase gene is on chromosome two. And the
FGFR3 gene, which, controls the trait of
achondroplasia, which causes dwarfism, is on chromosome four.
And let's say we have an individual who's
heterozygous for both conditions. They're heterozygous For lactase
persistence, so they are lactose tolerant, and they're
also heterozygous for the dominant allele that causes
dwarfism. Which means that they're also going to
be a little person. Now, to help us
know which plus and minus symbol goes with
which trait. I'm going to put in L next to
the alleles for lactose intolerance and a D next
to the alleles for dwarfism. Now instead of trying
to figure out all the probabilities of what
the next generation would be. Let's just focus in
on how this one person is heterozygous for both
of these traits is actually going to make their gametes.
And what are the possible allelle combinations for them to make
their gametes? So after meiosis, how many different allelic combinations or
genotypes can there possibly be for this individual? They're heterozygous for
the lactase gene and they're heterozygous for the gene causing dwarfism.